today close to 10 years after the
accession to the european union of
cyprus the czech republic estonia
hungary latvia the to enya malta poland
the slovak republic of slovenia we meet
to commemorate this truly historic event
today our combined population numbers
well over 500 million people this unique
achievement embodies maths of what the
Union stands for the overcoming of
centuries of conflict the transcending a
formal division in Europe and our will
to build a common future based on
cooperation solidarity respect for
diversity and mutual understanding I
will drag to end by pointing out one of
the most important lesson learned from
our search history by continued to work
together by promoting and upholding our
core union values reaching forward
towards common goals we will all be
better poised to confront the challenges
which we face both today and the future
together the 2004 big and la Big Bang
enlargement as well as a successive
existence of Romania and Bulgaria 2007
and Croatia to dance a team have a
further strengthened testability and
security of the whole continent these
are historic achievements for which the
European Union can be rightly proud and
it is no surprise that's a role
enlargement place in keeping Europe
stable and peaceful was reflected also
in the nobel peace prize awarded to the
european union in 2012 access and
benefited both those countries joining
say you and established member states
the economic dynamism of the then-new EU
countries generated 3 million new jobs
in just 6 years from 2002 to 2008 growth
in succeeding countries contributed to
growth in the existing member states
these figures speak for themselves
enlargement is a win-win for both sides
the low level of public support for
European integration and EU enlargement
in some Member State
is one of the challenges we are facing
what better commemoration of the 10th
anniversary is an a strong commitment
for all of us to continue efforts
towards building a real understanding
and awareness of the EU enlargement
policy and how it has shaped and
continues to shape Europe for the better
the enlargement expand in the area of
freedom democracy and prosperity in
Europe 10 years of membership is
completely different period of
development for lavenia and other nine
states in qualitative terms it
strengthened our state and societies in
the last 25 years we witnessed many
dreams coming to from a twin fall of
communism and berlin wall to the Big
Bang younes enlargement that made Europe
stronger and better equipped to fight
challenges and crises and promote
European values and we shall continue
working hard and never give up on our
dream so on a day when you commerce
appear let it be a homecoming and let us
speak the own strange words as it
behoves us here move lips move minds and
make new meanings Flair like II ancient
beacons signal in peak to peak from
middle C to north sea shining clear as
Phoenix flame upon Fiona ishka here